So what is kinetic energy? Well, it's ½ mv². I hope that right now you're seething.
I hope you're writhing in your chair and saying, Andy, that's not what kinetic energy is.
That's an equation that describes kinetic energy. What is kinetic energy?
Oh, what is kinetic energy? Well, it's the energy associated with motion.
Well, I hope now you were saying something like this,
because using energy to define kinetic energy isn't helping anything.
Well, this question has a short answer.
The short answer is, I don't know what energy is, but luckily, I know what energy does.
If you've had enough of this philosophical mumbo jumbo,
why don't we go ahead and actually solve some problems.
We had this idea, this work energy theorem.
It says that the total work on an object is equal to it's change in kinetic energy.
and since this is the equation for kinetic energy, well the change is just this.
The F means final velocity and Vi means initial velocity.
So why don't we solve a problem that we've solved previously using motion considerations,
but this time, let's solve it using the work energy theorem.
So, I want to know what is the ball's final velocity, if it's dropped from rest?
You can enter your answer here, and I know I haven't actually shown you
how to use this equation yet but you might be able to figure it out just by looking here,
and if you can, I think you still have the skills to answer this question.